straight ahead
on long crime daily we speak to a juror
in the derek shoving trial
how 12 people decided a former officer
was responsible for the murder of george
floyd
we were ready for for um for a guilty
verdict once you walk to the liberation
room
investigators want to test new dna
evidence in the so-called doomsday cult
couple case
was blood found in an apartment and
tools on chad davil's property
motion to oppose use of and motion to
preserve dna samples plus
is an indiana kidnapping related to two
unsolved murders from 2017
how a video taken by two teen girls
before their death
may solve this case and is an ohio
family of six
tearing at the seams as one co-defendant
pleads guilty in a deadly custody battle
everybody needs to step back and
reassess law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
everyone to law and crime daily i'm
brian buckmeyer along with terry austin
attorneys for the so-called doomsday
cult couple were back in court
and major news out of the department of
justice in the ahmad arbury case
but first to our interview with one of
the jurors in the derrick chauvin trial
law and crime's jesse webers spoke with
the juror about everything from opening
statements to deliberations
hey there brian yeah i spoke to brandon
mitchell now he's listed as potential
juror number 52 he's in the banking and
finance
industry he coaches youth sports and i
asked him what it was like to be a juror
in this monumental case
and also what happened behind closed
doors
the third degree murder is written out
very very weird um it's a lot of legal
jargon some of the a lot of the
terminology
that's written within that is very
confusing as it's read out does not have
to be we just wanted to make sure that
we were all on the same page
we all understood and we're
comprehending the
the third degree murder as it was
written the same way
we didn't want to be on possibly
different pages or interpreting it
differently we wanted to make sure we
all interpreted the same in order so we
can come to the same conclusion
you could have submitted questions as a
jury could have submitted questions to
the judge to the attorneys and yet you
didn't how come
um because we came to a conclusion as a
group so we i mean
we were all very intelligent and we
broke down the census structure we broke
down what it was what was being said and
um
everybody was able to understand it so
we didn't need to ask a question
if there was maybe a person or two that
still did work didn't understand then
yeah we would have
brought that question to the judge but
we pretty much got it figured out on our
own
just through just you know each other's
peers and just talking it out
did any of the defense's arguments
really stick with you you know eric
nelson really pushed forward the idea of
drugs in george floyd's system did that
give anybody pause during the
deliberations
um it didn't come into play really once
we're in the liberation room
but i know early on in the trial um
you know when nelson was just talking
about totality
of the case basically you know there'd
be some evidence that would basically
paint a bigger picture i'm pretty sure
all of us as jurors we were waiting for
that moment to where
that piece that one piece of evidence
would be like oh this this is what he
was referring to
kind of push that push them over the top
and be like oh this is this is obvious
i mean we just never got to that point
so yeah even him with him mentioning the
drugs it's like we didn't really
see um that that to be the cause of the
death
uh we just we just didn't get to that
point we just didn't see that as as
enough as sufficient
another big point that nelson focused on
was that the crowd of bystanders was
distracting
they were threatening did that ever come
up during deliberations did that become
a big issue
i thought that was uh probably his his
best point
um i didn't i didn't think the crowd was
overruly or
aggressive or anything but i thought if
he he could possibly create some doubt
in some of the juror's mind possibly
just by uh
because that's a perception type thing
of who's aggressive or who isn't a
little bit
so i did think that was possibly his
best point but it just wasn't it just
once again fell flat just because the
crowd wasn't it wasn't aggressive
there are people who look at this case
and say that derek chauvin could have
never gotten a fair trial
right i mean that the idea that the
jurors went in there
they already had an idea they were
already decided
what would you say to those people
you're one of the jurors you were in
that jury deliberation room what would
you say to the people
who say that this was not a fair trial
for derek chovin
yeah so i think that's just completely
ridiculous just because
um once you're in the courtroom and
you're
there and and you're a human being and
you're watching somebody die
on a day-to-day basis the stress and the
emotional draining and the mental mental
drainage that that causes
um you don't even think about anything
going on outside of there
you're now engulfed in and watching
these videos and hearing this agony and
this pain
um you have compassion for this person
that is on that
that's on these videos you're feeling
for them you're not necessarily thinking
about
uh you know the ramifications of what
could happen
you know oh if you if you go this way if
you go that way you're not thinking
about that because you're just watching
a person
die every single day
that's what you're watching and i mean
you feel for that you feel for that
and you just want to do what's right at
that point
thanks jesse and derek chauvin's legal
troubles don't seem to end with his
three guilty verdicts in minneapolis
the department of justice reportedly
plans to charge a former officer
according to the star tribune
prosecutors are asking a grand jury to
indict chauvin
as well as the three other officers
involved in george ford's death
the feds are seeking to charge all four
former officers with civil rights
charges
the news comes after the newspaper
reported that the doj was planning on
arresting chauvin at the courthouse if
he was not found guilty in his criminal
trial
now to georgia where federal officials
have announced hate crime charges
against three suspects in the death
of ahmad arbury a grand jury has
indicted gregory and travis mcmichael
as well as william rhodey bryant the
three men are charged with interference
with rights and attempted kidnapping in
the death of a mod arbory
both mcmichaels are also facing federal
charges of using guns to inflict
violence
and state charges for murder and
aggravated assault aubry was gunned down
in february 2020
the video of his death was released a
few months later the mcmichaels claim
aubrey was a burglar
running through their neighborhood
however both claimed they never saw him
steal anything
joining us today is defense attorney
imran ansari and terry austin
imran the doj is saying that mcmichaels
and brian targeted arbory because of his
race
pointing to not seeing aubry commit a
crime and the use of the n-word
is that strong evidence yeah brian i
think the strongest evidence
in support of these hate crime charges
is the fact that at the end of this
crime
one of the defendants used the n-word
they have to show that there was a
racial animus that propelled
this crime and there was a motivation
based on
a racial aspect i think that the
statement
by the defendant at the end would
support these charges
now georgia at the time did not have a
hate crime statue that
happened after the fact so that's why
there's no state hate crime charges
but terry nonetheless there are state
and federal charges
do you think the feds will take over and
the state charges could potentially be
dropped
you know brian i think they're both
going to proceed forward we don't have a
date yet for the state
charge but we do have the fact that the
federal crime is going to be
investigated and pursued
and the charges are totally different
one has to do with the hate crime as we
mentioned
and the other just has to do with the
state criminal crime
so you know the murder the aggravated
assault they don't need to prove
hate in the state crime so that is the
biggest difference and
don't forget there's also a civil
lawsuit against these individuals
by the family and it's a multi-million
dollar lawsuit so
there are a lot of charges facing uh
these individuals yeah and that civil
lawsuit doesn't just
go to the three individuals name there
it also goes back
uh to the actual office where those uh
individuals are
supposedly empowered by the police
department to look after that
neighborhood
thank you both still ahead on law and
crime daily the kidnapper of a 10 year
old girl is suspected
for the murder of two girls in delphi
indiana but first
the doomsday couple arrested for
concealing evidence is asking the
prosecution
to refrain from dna testing which may
lead to an upgrade in charges
we'll tell you why after the break
welcome back investigators of the
so-called doomsday cult duel are
attempting to conduct dna testing
as the couple's trial inches closer
lori valo and her husband chad dabel are
facing charges
for an alleged plot to conceal and
destroy evidence while valo's children
were reported missing
authorities discovered the bodies of
seventeen-year-old tylie ryan
and seven-year-old joshua j.j valo
buried in shallow graves
on dabel's property according to court
documents investigators want to conduct
dna testing
on tools found on the property and a
possible blood sample from an apartment
attorneys for the couple are requesting
the dna testing be postponed until the
defense can test samples on their own
the defense is also requesting to be
present at the lab on wednesday
the court held a sidebar for over an
hour before the judge came on the record
for less than two minutes council has
agreed to try to see
if this issue can be resolved through
stipulation
and there are some additional issues
that we're going to need
to find out from the state lab in order
to
potentially reach a stipulation and so
in order to allow time for that
it's my understanding the parties have
agreed that we should continue today's
hearing
with the proviso that the state would
agree to refrain at this time from any
consumptive testing of any
evidence in its custody at this time in
other words any testing that would
completely consume the evidence
backward as a defense attorney imran
ansari and terry austin
terry dna tests on the day bell's tools
explain what the prosecution is looking
for
and how it could amount to an upgrade in
charges
you know so far brian they only have
felony charges against chad and lori
for the destruction alteration or
concealment of evidence
the fact that they are looking at the
dna on the tools you know they
previously
hinted that they might be considering
more serious charges and now that they
are looking at this dna evidence
i think they could very well up the
charges for both of these
individuals and i am wondering my real
question is
if they've known about the bodies of jj
and tyler
since june of 2020 why haven't they done
this testing
long before now great question terry now
imran you're no
stranger to arguing dna if the
prosecution finds what they're looking
for
i'm assuming it's some sort of blood
splatter not contact dna or saliva
are the defendants all but convicted
well the defendants are going to be
looking to attack
whatever results that may be conclusive
or inconclusive from these tests
and if the dna is a hit on the
defendants the defense attorneys are
going to be looking to
attack the methodology attack the way it
was tested and still keep that
reasonable doubt as they go into trial
as to the dna testing dna is very strong
evidence so they're going to have an
uphill battle
if there's conclusive dna testing and
it's going to be interesting because the
prosecution gave the defense the heads
up that they were going to test these
items
because they believed that there was so
little dna that it would be consumed
makes me also question imran how many
picograms of dna
are there if it's so small but we'll
have to wait and see
new information is being released on a
november 2018 death of a grenada county
jail inmate in mississippi
law and crime's chief investigative
correspondent brian ross has more
thanks brian coming up this week on
brian ross investigates
calls for a federal investigation after
the release of a new video showing yet
another young
black man ending up dead in police
custody
police put him in the knee to neck
restraint for three and a half minutes
the way in which he's dealt with just
the humanity of it
they didn't even pull up his pants
that's this week on brian ross
investigates
on the law and crime trial network
thanks brian coming up on law and crime
daily ohio's largest murder case is
tearing one family apart
throwing the sixth co-defendant murder
trial up in the air
plus did a kidnapping suspect also
commit the murders of two indiana girls
more about the delphi murders and the
rescue of another teen ahead
we're back police in indiana rescued a
girl from the basement of a man's home
after they say she was kidnapped and
sexually assaulted investigators are now
looking into whether that same suspect
is behind the unsolved murders of two
teens in delphi
best friends 14 year old liberty libby
german and 13 year old abigail williams
were last seen hiking on the delphi
historic trail
on valentine's day 2017. their parents
report them as missing
when they didn't show up at their pickup
location the next day
volunteers discover their bodies in a
wooded area
investigators say the girls left a very
important clue behind
indiana state police say german recorded
a suspicious man following them
and someone can be heard saying guys
down the hill
well there's specific information in
this investigation
that we're not releasing that if it
comes to our attention
we're going to know that's a good tip we
need to really pay close attention to
that
no arrest has been made yet but a case
just 15 minutes away
is drawing new attention james chadwell
ii was arrested last week in lafayette
indiana police say a missing 10 year old
girl was found in the basement of his
home
with multiple injuries including bite
marks on her body
according to police chadwell invited her
into his home to pet his dogs
when he allegedly trapped her and tried
to strangle her chadwell is facing
charges of attempted murder
child molestation and kidnapping the
local sheriff's department is now
reportedly looking into chadwell to see
if he has any connection to the delphi
murders
people want to make the assumption that
the voice saying down the hill
it belongs to the person that's captured
in the image
from the cell phone that's not
necessarily the case
we're not making any assumption about
that we have more video
we have more audio but it is specific to
the investigation
and that's why it's not being released
at this time
here to discuss this true crime
mysteries defense attorney imran ansari
and co-host terry austin
terry do you think these crimes could be
connected by the same person
and why you know i think they might be
connected i will have to see what the
evidence says
but there are certain similarities the
fact that one lafayette
is 15 minutes from delphi it could very
well be
that this individual traveled back and
forth
they said that the young girl in the
basement had strangulation marks and
while the police aren't saying
that libby and abby had strangulation
marks there is some speculation that
they might have very well been strangled
and the biggest piece of evidence i
think connecting this individual to the
two girls
is the fact that the sketch looks a lot
like the video so it could very well be
connected we'll have to see what the
evidence says
yeah it looks close unsure whether or
not be beyond a reasonable doubt close
but we'll see how that plays out imran
these girls quick thinking may have left
clues of their own killer
what are officers likely looking at to
see if there's a connection between
that killing and this uh alleged
attempted murder
well we heard the officer talking about
that there's uh additional
video and audio and they're gonna see if
how they could connect it
possibly to this suspect and you have to
look at the
commonalities between the two alleged
crimes
and you have uh the victims are are
young female
uh children uh you have geographic
similarity
uh and there's some similarities in
terms of the modus operandi and i think
they're gonna be looking for those
connections
to see if there are in fact the same
suspect terry what do you think
geography m.o uh
just opportunity and that picture i mean
emma and i both looked at each other
when you saw that picture we're like uh
kind of close what do you think i think
the prosecution is going to pursue
this because they are looking for
someone it's been some time now and they
want to solve this case so
i think if they find enough evidence
they're going to go ahead and make that
connection and bring a case
absolutely going to find some sort of
corroboration maybe emerald what do you
think dna
fingerprints could that be helpful here
sure i think they're going to look at
the forensic evidence they have in terms
of the videos from the first incident
and connect that if they can with this
suspect and with this
second incident and also we're gonna
look at probably the testimony from this
young woman who
is in fact alive thankfully and see if
that's going to also corroborate
what we have evidence-wise from the
first incident all right we'll see when
we come back an alleged murderous family
of six
why one rogue member of the tight-knit
family may send them all to jail
next
welcome back an ohio man admits he and
his family slaughtered eight members of
another family
law and crimes angenette levy explains
how the guilty play
could tear apart the wagner family's
loyalty to one another
prosecutors have described the wagner
family as cult-like
but that could be changing as they sit
in jail awaiting trial
for the rodent and gilly murders
for the first time since his younger
brother jake confessed to investigators
george wagner appeared in court in what
was supposed to be a hearing to argue
motions
but jake wagner's guilty plea has
changed things
i think everybody's agreed that given
recent events
that everybody needs to step back and
reassess last week on the fifth
anniversary of the murders
jake wagner pleaded guilty to a laundry
list of charges including conspiracy
aggravated murder and unlawful sexual
contact with a minor
for his relationship with hannah may
rhoden the mother of his child
prosecutors say wagner admitted that
custody of that child was the motive for
the murders
i agree to what the state's provided
and i'm deeply and very sorry jake said
his family planned and carried out the
murders as most of the victims slept
the guilty plea represents a massive
split among the wagner family members
who had presented a united front for the
last five years
prosecutors wrote that the wagners
functioned as a unit at all times
residing together in a very insular
manner holding family meetings and
voting on all affairs
including when it came to children and
wives and sharing financial resources
and accounts it's not clear what george
wagner will do after learning more about
what his brother told investigators
and he said nothing as he left court
hi george do you have anything to say
wagner remains in jail where his
attorneys have said in the past he sits
in his cell
and reads the bible he'll be back in
court in june
for law and crime daily i'm angelette
levy
thanks angenet let's bring in imran and
terry one last time to discuss
imran jake wagner's guilty plea has to
be throwing in somewhat of a monkey
wrench for the other defendants
uh what do you think the attorneys for
the others are saying to their clients
right now
well i would be very concerned about the
information that was given to law
enforcement and to prosecutors
in advance of this plea deal and how
it's going to actually affect
each of those other defendants because
it may implicate them
it may make them criminally culpable and
i think that their defense is going to
be all the more complicated brian
after this development all right now
terry i agree with enron it's going to
get a lot more complicated but
it seems the death penalty is officially
off the table but do you expect
pleas or trials after this or could
maybe
another family member say that the
others were more involved than them
you know what brian anything is possible
this is what i'm hoping i am hoping that
we see
trials and that the prosecution doesn't
enter
into a plea agreement with any of the
other relatives because
anything less than a life sentence is
not going to be enough and we know that
it's a life sentence because the plea
deal that was taken
made sure that each of them got life
sentences
and that there was no death penalty for
any of them so as far as i'm concerned
the heinous nature of this crime makes
it so that they should serve
as long as possible and unless they have
something that
is additional or corroborating i don't
think they need to make
any deals at all imran maybe just my
defense attorney mindset is spinning
here if i'm representing another wagner
i may make the argument uh whether true
or not we got to see how the facts lay
jake wagner was coerced he's the younger
brother he's trying to help the family
maybe what he's saying is not as true
as it is maybe he's just trying to be a
good kid and save the family could that
be an argument for the other
wagners to save their case it could be
o'brien but it also could be the
argument that he's giving information to
save himself
and whatever deal he may have worked out
with the prosecutors i guess we're gonna
have to wait and see
exactly thank you for joining us here on
law and crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss
justice in america
you